Hello, welcome everybody. How is everybody doing today? This is going to be an
awesome listening and speaking class. I'm so glad that all of you are here. Welcome
everybody. Like training a muscle. The brain is not a muscle but we build
connections. We build stronger connections and so our aim today is for your
answers to try to be natural, fluent and clear. You might notice that I'm
typing as you speak. Try to look at some of these corrections that I'm making
some of them are just rephrasing of what you could say maybe a little bit
better. It improve your fluency. But I don't want it to interrupt your speaking.
Just try to focus on being natural, fluent and clear. The whole goal is to
understand and be understood. Here's a question. What's one thing you already feel
good about when speaking English? I don't know. That's a hard one. Okay, so I
think it's like now when I speak English, I don't feel like embarrassed if
something somebody correct me. So I think that's what something I feel good
now. That comes with experience really. That does help. And the next one, what's
one area you think might be challenging in an English interview and why? I think
it will be like the new vocabulary and (I) have to express or like as you mentioned
trying to put what I'm thinking in something like a more clear and in short.
*In size. Yes. Okay. And trying to say something clearly and concisely.
All right. I agree. All of these things can be improved too the more you do it. So we
could try to improve how we say things to make them more clear or concise in
today's lesson. One of the most popular interview questions that they ask is
tell me about yourself. They want you to open up. They want you to break the ice.
They've asked this question a million times. Some people use this in order to
impress the other person or like I said, break the ice. What do they really want?
What they really want is something brief, right? One to two minutes. A relevant
summary of your professional background, your skills, career goals, these
essential things that they need to know. Why? Because if this is the first question,
they need to have a very good one, a very strong positive first impression of
you for that first question they ask. Here's an activity for your dream job. What
are one to two key achievements or skills you'd highlight and your tell me about
yourself answer. What are two skills or achievements you would highlight? I think it
will be something related with decision making. And I think the other one will be
with like, I don't know how to say it's like when you learn something by
yourself. So one skill is that you are good at making decisions and that you
and the other one is that you know a lot about yourself. The other one is like if
I don't if I don't know something, I look for it until I know it. Okay. And I
learn, I try to learn by myself before I on your own. Right, so learn on my
own before I asked for help. So you consider yourself to be an autonomous
person. You're capable of working alone autonomously. Is that right? Yes, I can
work both, but yeah, I try to look first by myself. And I think this would
highlight the fact that you are capable of making good decisions that they're
not going to have to micromanage what you do that you trust that you can find
the correct answer that you're not going to be a burden on them and that you
have the necessary skills. I think that's a good way to make a good first
impression. Yeah, yes. So we have some different phrases that we can use to answer
this question. For example, if I were to tell someone about myself, I'd say my
name is David Brown. I'm passionate about teaching English as a second
language. I've had about 24,000 sessions online with students from all around
the world. I have taught younger students in middle school and high school
really identify with the work that I do in my free time. I think about it as
well. I like to spend time with my family and friends and dream about new
technology. I don't know. That's what I might have a job interview in a
little bit. Norma, tell me, do you think that would make a good first impression?
Yes. Oh, I hope so. I don't know if this lesson is better for me or for you
actually. Thank you. Thank you. Norma, this lesson is free. All right, so what made
that example easy to understand? I think I spoke a little bit too fast, but what
do you think? What made that example easy to understand? No, actually, what I
like listen (heard) was about the time that you have the experience that you have.
And also I can see like with the range of age that you can work. So
I know that you can do it with older or younger. And also that you are somebody
that takes care of our family. Okay, also, yeah, you have some good listening
skills already. What I, instead of saying what I listen*, you could say what I, what
I heard rather, you could say what I heard was about the experience that you
have and also see the age ranges you can work for. So I know you can work with
younger or older people. I understood you perfectly. All right, so we also have
this other really big question. It's always asked when you're asked what are
your strengths? We have a chance to shine. We can show other people what we've
got. What are your strengths, Norma? So you can, but what, but it's going to be
specific about this, right? Because we can, we can tell someone that we are good
listener, but when were you a good listener? And what situation can you be more
specific? This can really help. If you can demonstrate specific, specific
examples. And then when you're asked, what is your greatest weakness? You can
choose a real minor weakness you're actively improving. So this shows that
you're honest. And they say that you should avoid cliche is like, I'm a
perfectionist, unless you can generally back it up. Are you really a perfectionist?